Opie and Jimmy continue on with the show
if your character's supposed to be a Jew
but they don't want to we're on it
I like you so I'll shut you up right now
yeah it is entered yeah Dick Cavett has
entered the studio and has already
entertained us for the last 10 minutes
with Impressions yeah I I would love it
we should have waited for the radio
there was some good stuff but I just I
would like to say for the record I
wasn't entertained by anything
that is true David interrupted and
heckled the entire time
when you're on stage
[Laughter]
we were just talking about Hillary just
before the mics went on and uh yeah that
was a real surprise in Michigan yeah
first year here we're sitting here in
the shock waves of uh Bernie's right
announcing her in Michigan nobody even
predicted it would be close I thought uh
she had like a 12 point lead or
something like that going into it and
they get a refund on the polls that
people charged them for it was close
though it was just uh 49.9 to 48.2 so
yeah but it wasn't supposed to be no
they split the delegates more or less 65
to 58. but more importantly how do you
rearrange uh Hillary Clinton's name to
spell out a sentence Oh that's what you
are well see I I can't do my anagrams if
I'm asked
you do anagrams yeah it's a curse and I
remember it'd be sitting there in the
show and talking to somebody
will Spiro Agnew singular worst guest I
ever had of it really why dismal dough
boring and unfunny everybody said he'd
be swell oh wow all I could think of and
should have said is do you realize
if you rearrange the letters of your
name it spells grow a penis
do you see those things
do you see those in your head instantly
or do you sort of the one that scared me
I had been playing a word game one
summer with some people out there
sharing a house with and you rearrange
letters to make as many words as you
could on the table move them around
and I've got so
I could do it without wanting to I
remember driving in in Mr donut sign was
there and I donut was burned out so it
just said mister and I thought Mr
miter's timers remits merits
all of those no it's it's a quirk that's
a little insane oh cool I hope it
doesn't happen when you hear the word
ginger
[Laughter]
the G word
um or maggot
go maggot here's the one though
2 A.M driving past the old East Hampton
movie theater
when an old Marquee the kind you put the
letters up and I guess some kid put them
up and didn't know one actor from
another and looked and see who's in the
movie and he'd put up Lawrence of Arabia
starring Alec Guinness
and I had just done a show with O'Toole
so I was going to take a picture and so
he'd know who the star of the Lord
and the little voice said genuine laces
no no genuine class
that's Elegance right huh so your mind
just rearranges those yeah no it's
that's a brilliant epic a reality and I
reject it and change it absolutely I did
that once Lewis friend iron sulfide
science Lance that's Beauty yeah that
was that was uh inside the lamps Hannah
Belcher would do these uh anagrams it's
great
[__] is it really oh wow nice Jesus it's
a direct message to god wow
you said it so what do you think of this
election Mr Cabot that's pretty I'd
rather talk about almost anything I
understand did you hear about Trump
though well how about this we we said
earlier we haven't seen anything like
this in our lifetime I mean have you
ever seen anything this crazy there's
nothing comparable to this there's
nothing right but a man without a single
skill needed to be the president of the
United States uh who is repulsive
misogynistic and so cleverly cleverly
people could learn from him showed how
not to offend the clan or the white
supremacists by using a word they
probably didn't even know disavow right
is that all you have to say about them
and he was winking I'm sure at the time
you know Trump yeah Trump yeah I love
him yeah but if Dick Cavett doesn't like
him I'm not gonna lie what do you see in
him I like the fact that he's just
wrecking this experience for the rest of
them
I should have known knowing you yeah I
like that he's calling everyone out the
media the politicians how and how
they've campaigned over the years you
know because we're I think we're all
sick of these politicians speaking in
sound bites and not really speaking
their minds I think instead of in the
lies he's got so popular because it's a
matter of like saying stuff everyone's
so scared to say anything nowadays so
someone speaks their minds it's like oh
good yeah political correctness
you can speak his mind as he proves and
I prove several times
if you ever speak your mind it's all
over
what happened we need a new insurance
duck yeah
a lot of things that Nixon did only
Nixon was at least intelligent well
informed and clever about it so Nixon
had his southern strategy which he was
able to bring off without
openly offending you know before you
came in here well before he came in here
it was an entertaining show but
and then they got you
everyone was having fun for everyone
the people at home must Wonder but it's
somewhat true they were telling farmers
and daughters
we were having a square dance
Travis Howard said in some movie Very
movingly upon hearing upon someone's
death
oh my God I am sorry
we had a part game is what we're saying
you talking Nixon Nixon was [__] was
uh what was gunning for you at one point
because of an anti-war or like six or
eight points oh really yeah I can still
get Fun by tuning to the thing I think
it's probably still on YouTube where you
see the great unindicted co-conspirator
himself sitting in the Oval Office with
his
to use an Elizabethan term lick spittle
H.R Haldeman and uh the words now Jim
you've got you've indulged in licks I
certainly have
well I didn't want to bring that up yeah
it's a fetish I paid for strap-on and
elixir that's a great story
I remember the cop show strap-on
strap-on and licks
I think it was you with John Chuck not
suitable for adults
so
the first words that since there's a
still photo but it it gives the
impression that they're talking because
the words go and the sound from Nicks
and tapes and it begins what is Cabot
anyway and called him and says oh he's
the worst he loads every show with some
of the Nixon interrupt and goes on but
the beautiful last line is he comes back
to the subject and says Cabot there must
be something we can do to screw him wow
oh that's an honor yeah yeah and didn't
he respond we've been trying to
you know too much in fact yes I almost
forget this
but I didn't obviously didn't know about
the time because it's when the tapes
were discovered and years later they're
playing them now but um yeah uh he did
manage to screw by the way if screw was
the nicest word in his vocabulary he was
the filthiest Mouse son of a
mother right and um it's part of his
obsession with his manhood you know he
was always saying so-and-so's a real man
and then making that little first thing
he did with his mouth but anyway
um we can't blame him for that but yeah
here's what happened ran into a woman of
my staff who'd been on it years earlier
and she said I ran into Arlene who was
also instead and she said she'd been
audited
I said and then I said well I was
audited too what year was it and it was
the same year so the bastard I mean the
unprincipled president
couldn't get at me really as much as he
wanted
and because I had
obeyed John Lennon's request to come
down and testify that he shouldn't be
thrown out of the country by uh the
Yorba Linda Wonder
and and uh it was it was just a case of
um
nastiness extreme nastiness on his part
he audited everybody on my staff which
of course hurt the as some would say the
little people right so the phrase of
Jones I I had um David Steinberg on the
podcast yeah Steinberg here Steinberg
and he said you know you used to do
Nixon jokes yeah and then he would find
when he was on tour people in the
audience would start heckling him really
when he'd start doing the Nixon jokes
and then he started to recognize the
hecklers at that they were following him
and like it was sent over and then some
guy came along and he said look I know
you've been having trouble I'm with the
FBI I'll protect you I'll travel with
you
and then this guy who was his protection
when all this Watergate stuff happened
he's watching the news and the guy
sitting next to Nixon no yeah wow that
was creepy is that his great story or is
that the signs of mental illness
[Laughter]
like when he was in China and they took
him to the great wall and you remember
what he said what this is indeed a great
wall
who said that next index we were talking
about the time you well you always
that's what I remember when you'd have
uh when you'd have Groucho on yeah yeah
and that's the best aging Groucho ever
done I just I just watched that again on
YouTube the 1969 thing is that the good
one the one where he has the golfer yeah
oh yeah with the little golf balls
there's a storybook story
you know
up
now the Hop accident was a musical
instrument that huge hit the strings and
it would make a sound it would make
music this is cruel
music back then was something that had a
melody and if you shoot people at home
Gilbert's head there's Groucho singing
Lydia
the tattoo not that hat what do you love
to know what became of it yes yes
someone's got that there it is again
what story this well go ahead I had to
go out soon 10 times I think maybe 12.
and Jesus that's more he was on with
that hat with Truman Capote wow and when
you had Truman on you had to brace
yourself because the minute he spoke the
audience laughed every time he was as
Norman mailer said a ballsy little guy
and it didn't bother him but
Groucho on that show proposed marriage
to Truman
and Capote was no fool
and congratulations so what about my
offer and Capote said yeah
I could never marry a man who has three
balls on his hand
oh my God I can't get back to my own
voice now
you're with Brandon when he punched at
paparazzi
yeah he knocked uh Ron galella they
broke his jaw
eight inches from my face Maybe six wow
what were you guys doing one of them
thrillingest moments
but didn't this galella then follow him
with like a football helmet yeah with an
eagle feather yeah and it's a wonder he
didn't get whacked again but uh
so you I didn't hear that case came out
for a long time and I
then the next time I saw Marlin I said
um what about the gorilla thing and he
said
best fifty six thousand dollars I ever
spent
might have been 26. a lot of money in
those days yeah yeah yeah so you guys
were just walking to eat or something
right and he just came up and he got
well no um
after the show I did with Rando he said
he wants a little Chinese restaurant and
I said sure
he was trying to find an old Chinese
restaurant that he'd known in his old
days and we went down to Chinatown and
it was uh
that picture
um
and it was Chinatown was closed in
effect it looked like the closed
chinatown's standing set at Universal or
something couldn't find it colella
pulled up
hopped out of the car with his assistant
and I said oh God it's clearly what's
one of those going on
I said the bigger one
I'll I'll cut to the moment
hey Marlon take off those sunglasses
don't you can tell if there's some
pictures of him what'd you say leaning
in
once you get time to take that oh wow a
sucker punch in the middle of a sentence
he does that in two movies wow that's
Jesus it came up from the sidewalk I
swear to God it lifted galila the
between the first and second knuckle the
teeth
entered the gorilla hand
and did you know that morse's humanists
is the dirtiest wound you can get women
bite oh really oh he'd been Brando's
hand from here you like Latin in this
way yes I do
there we are just before the moment
you both have on like Necker chips yeah
why I don't know it's a style back then
73. you kind of look like Woody Allen
stunt man
and he looks like a predator of some
sort yeah it's scary you don't want to
mess with that that version of Marlon
Brando we got in a cab yeah
and the driver was Chinese
and he ordered us out of the cab
and they said
about you because I see you fight I'm
not good
it's hard
and Marlon said he turned on that surge
of power that only he could do on the
screen and said
we're going to the Russian Tea Room
funnily enough we passed
with his wound
seeping
um
Last Tango on a marquee so that that
dates it for me when it was Last Tango
was just uh
I was working at time as a copy boy and
a woman came in
who worked there and said Jesus I just
saw it
Greening of this new movie as Tango
right the beginning Marlon just throws
this woman up against the wall and [__]
her right on the screen
and I thought is there a cartoon
what a guy what about that picture of
him that we've talked about recently
that famous picture of him blowing Wally
Cox or something they they did at a
party people yeah I saw that yeah I
never heard of that that people said
that they started sending another form
of that picture and it has something to
do with a carrot and a horse and then
they turned it into there is such a
picture
there you go this picture made the
rounds whoa it's okay Brando is blowing
a horse he was not blowing well yeah
everyone is much younger no no one is a
mimic this is even much younger in this
one yeah right there he's younger you
could tell right I can tell it's brand
new
it looks like him I guess but yeah I
think he's they said and and how did
Wally Cox get a black [__] yeah yeah
that's just a light easy breakfast
the pictures that's been making the
rounds for many years but they were
[__] each other weren't they Marlon
Brando and Wally Cox not while I was
there
they were they had an apartment there
were three people the three individuals
as a cup would say uh the one individual
of course was Marlon and the other one
was Cox and the third one was a raccoon
he had a pet raccoon do you really yeah
where Brando did yeah they shared I mean
Marlin did yeah he said I could call him
that what was it like going out with him
my God Marlin's an anagram for normal
isn't it hey oh wow oh god oh this is
scary please add the second name it's
normal and Broad
uh-huh and brought
it's too late to tell him I know he knew
though he knew he probably figured that
out one night I'm sure you could get
that what's his name John Edwards or
something who speaks to the dead yeah
perhaps people so what what was Brandon
like to go out with uh like you going
out with probably the biggest star in
the world yeah I would remind myself of
that but it didn't seem that way it was
personable and you know I like to talk
and
uh he gave me unreadable books that he
was here about philosophy and okay now
here's the thing I suspect about Brando
and and it's it's a quote a famous quote
from Truman Capote that always stayed
with me because I believe it a New
Yorker piece okay Capote yeah uh Truman
Capote said that all actors are dumb
and I I believe that I know what he
meant but I gave him a very bad time
because he said it on a show of mine
and it sort of Tainted our relationship
and you can't afford to be intelligent
because they have to have no personality
or mine they have to absorb other
people's minds and personalities and I
said that is so much crap Truman I know
actors who would make you look like a
member of the Jukes family
most people don't know that reference
they were a feeble-minded as they used
to see if they don't sound brightness
were too uh see at first I thought you
said that make you look like a member of
a Jew family yeah
well Google the Jukes now do you believe
that the usual way no now Mr Cavett do
you believe I I feel like Senator Joe
McCarthy huh you call me Mr dick yes Mr
Dick
Mr you make it sound awful do you
believe that I uh it's coming out now
that Hitler like to get [__] on
no it was a well-known comedian well
Danny Thomas we know it we've heard that
yeah we already know about Danny Thomas
now now news is coming out Hitler like
to get [__] on but without the glass
coffee table
oh no how did this come out now come out
it's an interesting word
what uh they said they found old old
medical records about his mangled penis
there's been these weird rumors about
him in toilet games for years yeah of
course
um
I get a laugh now at a personal
appearance but for some reason because
one night I somebody said do you like
everybody in Show Business dumb question
from the audience and I said no there's
some of the worst people in the world
are well-known stars and business
and terribly disliked Jack Benny was
probably the most loved man in the
business ever his generosity his
kindness all the things he
and then at the other end of the scale
there was um
well a comedian I won't say his name
but his initials are Danny K
he was real dick huh I heard he was
hated yeah everyone I've spoken to
who've met him has hated him what was
wrong yeah what was his problem yeah
prickness oh just a princess in general
rude
ungrateful Tony Curtis's book Tony
Curtis says he ran into Danny K at a
party and Danny K was very insulting
kept insulting him and finally Tony
Curtis said [__] you Danny
I love weird and everything
I'll try to make this quick but Danny K
came on my morning show
in those days I still liked him to me
he's a comedian you grow out of as a kid
you think he's great and later anyway he
came on he adored me which is always
kind of embarrassing many of the worst
people Adore Me
I'm a big gamer I couldn't think of a
compliment to give him because I had
soured on him years earlier but there he
was in the audience was in awe of him
and I said you know you are what am I
going to say what am I going to say you
are the most graceful of all comedians
oh yes and things you could do
physically and verbally
and that night he broke his ankle
not everybody was happy and he came back
on him he was out of this he was on the
show that Hammerstein musical flowering
from flowering Peach whatever it was on
Broadway in which he distinguished
himself in Boston by unzipping A Lady's
dress during a serious song she was
singing and he spoke to me boys and
girls three times from the stage the
night I was there I got farther and
farther down oh you're uncomfortable now
now show me if you've heard this
it got free does it
by the way that's a devastating thing to
you
[Laughter]
um
anyway what was I talking about oh the
last night of that musical when it's a
wonder he hadn't been murdered by the
entire cast
which sold out every night he was in it
he took two weeks off and they had 20
people per night and then he came back
and showed his great power anyway the
last night closing night
in a moment of generosity he gave
everybody a making a gesture about six
by six foot piece of wood
um inlaid probably from dunhills a
cheese board with a nice little silver
knife for cutting the cheeses with its
pardon the expression for severing the
cheese from and uh
everybody got one probably 90 of them
all the gypsies everybody
they all hurried home or out of the
theater to see him come out can you see
it coming through the alley and all the
cheese boards were in the garbage
wow every single one
he couldn't miss it okay now most
importantly
were were Danny Kaye and Lawrence
Olivier sucking each other's [__]
that's a great question yeah
I think only one was
that again
that's another uh unkillable rumor in
the business isn't it wow yeah I've seen
that photo of Olivia and him though in
that mirror okay Danica was in good
shape for meeting comedian's usually not
[__] ripped like that he's ripped uh
well he did a dirty trick on new Olivier
yeah he set it all up so that when he
came through customs once and oh he put
on a disguise strip uh strip search in a
room
and then the guys revealed themselves as
people hired by Danny day huh was he uh
was he a funny comic though isn't like I
don't remember anything he did Danny K
yeah you didn't grow up in the right
time to see him in uh Hans Christian
Anderson Mary Andrew
the one where he does a fabulous duel
with the great basil Rathbone who was
the best swordsman in Hollywood by the
way
um
and you should see make a point of
seeing the funny ones oh Hans Christian
Anderson and oh and and The Secret Life
of Walter Mitty oh and um what's the one
with all the beautiful
complicated articulate songs that he
does so well
well if Debbie does one in every movie
his wife wrote all his great material
for him and he was apparently a [__] to
her I don't like musical comedies though
that type of stuff never really I prefer
slapstick yo this isn't like no Marietta
or so it's um
what's the one that he's the fun the
gesture is in the title Court Justice oh
is that with the pestle with the
something vessel with the pistol or the
flag and with the dragon or something
with the something as the brew that is
true and the great Mildred natwick
that's that's from there sort of any
video of that I just
and he gets it mixed up and but it's
quite brilliant Carlin liked him huh
loved him I didn't know that it was
Carlin's guy huh yeah the audience at
home oh no no Carlin
worshiped him yeah growing up yeah and
then he said one time he he was waiting
outside the theater where Danny K was
gonna come out and there were other
group of kids and Danny K was like you
know basically get the [__] away from me
yeah that's right there are 100 stories
like that about him and um and yet he
was publicly
UNICEF or one of the children's thing
well that's that's what he used to be
when he was with Lawrence Olivier is
that another word for yeah yeah
George was George Carlin yeah
that's a great trick that was Jerry
Lewis canned from the Telethon
I don't know because it's so funny
nobody says the muscular dystrophy
telethonia we say that Jerry Lewis or
Jerry Lewis show the Jerry Lewis show
yeah and and ever since he was canned
nobody cares about muscular dystrophy
anymore they fired Emery I remember when
he had raised millions and millions and
somebody wrote an article saying this is
money utterly wasted we're not getting
aware with this disease no recent
research has produced anything
um and one of the stories of the Jerry
just spent a million a year on Cadillac
Limousines and things for himself and
I don't know yeah didn't he step down
they're saying he stepped down no I
think they fired him yeah the man who
did it at an odd cocktail party yeah
distinguished moment in life as I forgot
to fire Jerry Lewis oh wonderful now
Jerry was as people say in Joe business
always nice to me oh yes yes there is a
dear friend of mine I I worked for him
yeah oh you wrote first that's right
that two-hour spectacular oh my God that
was a disaster like having been on the
Hindenburg gave him two hours to do
whatever he wanted with yeah and it was
like and I was a kid and I loved Jerry
Lewis so I wanted and even as a kid I
thought oh this is a piece of [__]
I could do an hour on that show I I
imagined a little voice in Brooklyn was
it saying this is a piece of [__] it
must have been you oh yeah
but it's like ever since they fired
Jerry Lewis then the next Telethon was
like an hour long or something late Jack
Bailey or something yeah and it's that's
a name you don't know isn't it Jack
Bailey Jack Bailey he was a kind of a CD
I hope his daughter isn't listening a
kind of a CD host of
very low level game shows for years and
years Jack Bell and the Great Jack Parr
yeah
the year I started working for him and
Jack took the show to Hollywood for the
second time before that he couldn't get
anybody Jack was new
he couldn't get any guess
this trip a typical four guest show
would be Red Skelton and Peter Laurie
and Olivia de Havilland and Carrie Grant
or something
Jack got everybody
and in the first monologue he said I I'm
so thrilled the people we have on the
next two weeks the last time we were
here I had to pull strings to get Jack
Bailey
that's perfect wording Jack was a
brilliant ad labor he hasn't had enough
credit for that
we all know our friend Fat Jack Leonard
right I know the name I know De Niro is
a big fat Jackie Leonard fan aren't you
uh yeah yeah
I lost more weight than you are once you
put your glasses on backwards and walk
into yourself
he was very funny a lovely man he always
brought cufflinks and things gifts to
the staff when he was on tonight's show
and I liked him a lot and but Jack came
up one night to me and said you know Fat
Jack's on tonight you know how when he
says something you have to say something
back and then he plays off that and then
you have something you have I'm not
going to say anything I'm just going to
sit there
so fat jack comes on he starts doing his
stuff let's put your glasses on the back
and walk into yourself and when a woman
who was so concerned
text says nothing well I'll tell you my
cousin is so very nothing Jack Puerto
Jack started to Leonard started to sweat
it was almost sad Jack would just sit
there at the most say indeed Mr Leonard
and finally Jack Leonard desperate
reached for something to say a fact from
his life
he said you know my wife's an acrobat
and Jack said she'd have to be
brought down the hills I told him about
later he didn't remember it he uh what
was the big fight that Jack Parr had
with Walter Winchell didn't they go back
and forth
yeah I'd kind of forgotten that yeah
Jack was the only one with the courage
to attack the great Walder windshield of
course Walter windshield had lost a
couple of his fangs by that time and uh
it was sort of a pathetic character
but he what's the movie with Tony Curtis
and that's supposed to be based on
windshield oh uh the sweet smell of
success yeah I wish it was powerful
cruel
bigoted
turd and um
but nice
one day I get a phone call Mr Winchell
would like to talk to you
this is way after his the height of his
career but he was the voice on The
Untouchables brilliant oh yes because
his show always began with right even Mr
Mrs North American all the ships let's
see let's go to press Washington he had
that kind of delivery he'd been a Vaude
vision
Walter Winchell wants to take you to the
Copa tonight
and I had to get into a tux
because he was wearing one
and this old fossil who had been a giant
in his day
showed that my apartment picks me up
tax cummerbund a 38 in the cummerbund
because he thought they were out to get
him and in fact they'd forgotten him wow
oh geez and he liked to get in the car
during his whole career he had a police
radio he had permission to have a police
radio so he'd chase down calls and get
stories that way
and the police radio and going there we
went down to some Precinct
there was nothing there
it
got a guy for loitering or something
and windshield just didn't want to leave
the police station because that used to
be where hey Walter great that none of
the young cops knew who he was
and some kids said hey mister
talk again
oh yeah you're the guy from The
Untouchables
and windshield just glowed and dropped
about 20 years
identified for his voice on a television
show
but what did he do with the rest of his
life I don't know
sounds like it was it was a bastard he
was in there yeah really there he is now
I'm especially important at Columbia
hospital Washington Mr Brown is New York
City's next Commissioner of
Investigation New York City it's a baby
boy for the John costellos at Leroy
Sanitarium
Nancy Donovan New York City hear this
Dorothy Parker the famous playwright and
poet will make a speech in New York on
the 17th of the hall in Greenwich
Village probably on Fourth Street on
behalf of the Communists now in American
jails for conspiring to overthrow the
United States good girl good girl bro
what a cool delivery yeah yeah dramatic
I heard he was really Pro like McCarthy
oh he was a rabbit there to come his
mccarthiest
and one night he said live on the
Nationwide radio where everybody
listened to him and a president who
doesn't know what the h-e-l is going on
that was Truman so that almost ended his
career for saying Hell on the radio or
foreign
Winchell yeah yeah huh and I heard
during the show Danny K used to bloom is
that Danny K Used To Blow Walter when
what was that Marlon parental in the air
yeah I think Marlon Brando and Wally Cox
yeah would be under his desk
you are going to leave your brain to a
Harvard lab
it does explain some of the stuff we've
got to stop the Communist Menace a
little less teeth now on to him
that's quite good
so what do you think these guys you get
them to dance and do all this cool stuff
on your on your show it just seems like
the celebrity interviews now are so much
different they're not like free-flowing
they're not comfortable I don't know
what that is people always say nobody's
doing what you did and I don't know what
that is for one thing I had 90 minutes
which in some ways is easier than doing
seven with somebody can I explain what
it is Mr Cabot uh because me and Godfrey
were talking about before you came in
here nowadays late night talk shows
every minute every second is important
they got to fill up the space you would
let the the room breathe and feel that
urgency all the time it's an urgency and
it's also obvious that no there's no
surprises there's the pre-interview
where it's like all right we're gonna
talk about this this and this and I I
would bet you that you barely had a
pre-interview back in your day and you
would like Jack Paris established how
that kind of talk show worked maybe
Steve Allen did essentially there was a
staff with a number of people who would
call
Peter eustanov or whoever the great
guests were the bad guest yeah and say
if anything you want to talk about or
they would just say I don't need
anything I Know Jack or dick or whatever
and I found one of the best things you
could do is abandon your notes right
away of course because the best advice
and all the other only one more time
came from Jack Parr
most neurotic exciting strange
Troublesome hateful at times brilliant
TV presence ever danger sense of danger
and everything he did anyway he called
me up
he was off by then I was starting I said
Hey kid listen I got one piece of advice
whatever you do on the talk show don't
do interviews
I thought what do I do sing the whole
show he said no no interviews you know
that's q a and what's your favorite
color and David Frost and his damn
clipboard and his jet lag and what do
you think of him and what he didn't make
it a conversation I it's it's funny on
talk shows when the hosts will go hey
you know I don't remember I read
somewhere or overheard you are stuck in
an elevator in a gorilla suit and it's
like yeah that wasn't prepared that just
came up in conversation that phrase I
read somewhere yeah or somebody said the
other day
uh yeah but some people are hard to
converse with but when a conversation
goes and you you're thinking I just
can't wait to talk about this and talk
about that and instead of that jury
Midwestern Little Junior High School
girls question who's been your most
interesting guest
my most interesting gift
how can you answer who's your favorite
guest well how can you say right there's
a winner among thousands of interesting
people I I'd have pushed to the wall I
say Groucho meant the most to me there's
the Hat with the three balls
what about a Woody Allen you guys had
some great riffing yeah he he was on a
lot of times at the beginning and from
the daytime show and others
Woody when he started appearing
on television
was on the Merv Griffin show
and he was new and paralyzed with nerves
but he acquitted himself well
the name Henry Morgan may not mean much
to you oh yeah you will yeah but Woody
did a stand-up on Merv very nervous I
was there to calm him and get muscle
exercises and then he sat down and
Morgan was a little nasty and Woody had
done a piece about his mother I think
Merv said Henry
you and Woody both do comedy do you have
much in common or something and Morgan
said I do but referring to Woody's piece
but I had two parents
and the audience kind of went
and Woody said what were they
he's forgotten it
those moments were so great there was a
great one of between Richard Pryor and
Milton Burrough I think it was on Mike
Douglas oh that was so awesome
where they got angry I I'm Milton burrow
was telling a story about some girl who
had gotten an abortion it was important
to him and prior I think laughed or did
something yeah he started laughing he
was probably stoned out of his head or a
little nervous right here and uh and uh
but if you have your headphones let's
play this yeah let's take his headphones
no wonder I've missed everything hold on
all right yeah let's play this is that
okay yeah
I'm sorry man but just I'm just I just
did it
I wish I wish Richard that I could have
laughed
at that time at your age
when I was your age the way you just
laughed now but I just couldn't I told
you this nine years ago and I'll tell
you on the air for a millions of people
pick your spots baby
all right sweetheart
[Music]
well he said dick he said he said Milton
said pick your spots baby and Richard
Pryor went all right sweetheart right
but Pryor said he felt bad about that
afterwards he didn't want to argue with
Milton bro he liked Milton bro wow yeah
it was a very uncomfortable by the way
the saddest thing among the people in
this room
is that I'm probably the only one who
heard Fred Allen all the years that Fred
Allen was probably the wittiest
person in Show Business along with
Groucho and George's Kaufman
and uh
in a letter to Groucho Fred Allen
didn't do well in television he was
great with
and in a letter to
Groucho who had asked why do you think
Fred Milton Burl has a smashing success
and Alan wrote
Milton is the morons Messiah
see but Fred Allen
I it's not a matter of good looking I
bet he he was disturbing looking yes he
was almost he had a very pinched face he
was a
people of a certain age might remember
him in the last years that he was
visible which was on What's My Line as a
panelist yeah
um I think I'm here to talk about myself
he had an unhealthy look like big bags
under his eyes yeah I'm sure they're
going to come up with a picture
yeah okay
I want to see what he looks like just a
picture of his face there you go yeah oh
yeah he's an odd looking guy yeah once
in a while to this day a stage hand or a
camera assistant or somebody will come
up to me and say you remember that roast
you were on way back with uh burl
then I say yeah
I was
it was too soon for me to rank being on
with it but Jack Rollins got me into
things before I was really earned them
so I'm on this big Celebrity Roast as
one of the roasters
hemian and Smith special craft music
called both sides
Milton is the host
and this is the what the guy reminded me
of
Milton got up and he started in his
usual
crass and often funny way
and I said the kid spoke Mr Burrell yeah
are we allowed to ad-lib with you
he was very irritated but even he said
you want to add with me I'll check my
brains and we'll start even
and I said where would you find a small
enough check room
well it doesn't quite scan logically but
it killed of course it did God and the
bastard came over to where I was sitting
and said oh yeah I see you had that
written out
he was a bit of a schmuck but why did
you like this powerful comedian seeing
Burl in a club yeah
really almost terrifyingly
powerful well like like the entire
Saturday Night Live that he was on his
legendary as far as everybody hated him
oh yeah do they have Milton bro yeah oh
I never heard yeah he had that what am I
doing now oh there was a picture of me
on something uh maybe that roast but to
this day
um a Workman on a show will come up and
say I think it's got a Milton bile that
time I'll never forget it I don't know
why that's so funny Fred Allen here's a
bit of Comedy history a bunch of them
used to sit around I think at Ruby Foos
Alan King other Comics Hanny people and
wow compete for it was so wind it was so
hot it was so old it was so cute
he said
Fred Allen always won
and they were all I'd lived and nobody
knew what were they gonna say my
favorite was
it was so windy I saw a hen lay the same
egg twice
laughs
wow that's that's a lot of wind yeah
that's that certainly is a lot of an egg
back into a vagina
oh is that what it means yes
Gilbert looked a little puzzled it
immediately went from intellectual
oh honey you have no rural backgrounds
absolutely you see boys talk the way you
need to I'll just focus on getting [__]
it's similar to The Great SJ Pearlman
referring to psychiatrists as as
Skechers as a head candle if you don't
have a rural background you don't know
what candling is you know what it is you
candle an egg you hold it up to see if
it's been
impregnated or whatever or if it's still
an egg to a candle flame so a
psychiatrist was a headcan so you hurt
Pride was uh wasn't happy with that with
the thing with pearl yes I heard that he
respected Milton and he felt like he
regretted that yeah he wished it didn't
happen or he didn't want to argue with
him and he kind of backed off like you
know I mean I think at that time prior
could have been pretty I mean I wish I
had known this hey can you imagine how
strange it feels a week and a half ago
I'd have some they come up and say you
were great last night with Richard Pryor
all right I thought this guy's nuts
they're running my old shows starting
about three weeks ago on cbs's new uh
digital channel called decades
you have to Google decades and see I
don't know what the outlet is in New
York they just go dick cavettshow.com
and he's also promoting Brief Encounters
it's a new book that's available now we
forgot to mention that we haven't even
talked about it yet I love your show I
love this the way you spoke to people it
was so casual and natural it was a
conversation it was a conversation like
you said a little earlier well the one
that ran yesterday we get this Trio it
was Muhammad Ali
Lawrence Harvey and Jersey Kozinski that
fraud who
committed suicide oh now why do you say
he was a fraud this is interesting uh
because it's a fact
what he didn't write that stuff yeah he
did and he made up a background he made
up an idea for himself a country for
himself it's too bad he was a terrific
guest and I liked him immensely and then
this to find somebody that fooled you
the total
bogus character that he was and
committed suicide I don't know whether
he was about to be exposed well I think
he was exposed during his lifetime yes
was it in that time he committed suicide
like right after yeah yeah it was
obviously a contributor yeah
um okay from something
I think it was Gilbert is it
I first did it to a guy once who was
interviewing me out in the Midwest and
he had told everybody what great buddies
we were and I had never met him
and it just did it so relentlessly that
they said when you go in the air with
him is there anything you can do to him
and so we talked for this this great
friend of mine and I talked for about an
hour and then I finally said
um
so uh Peter is it
nearly he crumpled I felt awful about it
was the joke about milk you must know
the joke about Burl in a nightclub
big dick over somewhat Jewish dialect no
what is it I saw girls naked ass but I
never saw his
prodigious member the way that if it
weren't for burls
um schlong
half the Friars club's roast would have
would be empty yeah
I heard a new one Georgie Jessel
Georgie Jessel another name the young
have no idea of in some cases hello Mama
yeah
yes practicing spots before he rides
what one did you put on your glasses
darling Oh now you can see the spot's
clearer hey did you get did you get that
palette I sent you what you ate it but
that pirates wrote 10 different
languages all he could have said
something
then he and and his famous song one word
[Music]
that taught me wrong from right
I found in my eyes
what's cold
My Mother's Eyes just like him
straight no hole till I reach my goal
all lights
on selfish love I found them
mother's eyes
[Music]
that's that is prodigious my God you're
you're a gold miner yeah but you know
the only thing you know no I'm not I'm
not I'm not criticizing yeah no the only
the only thing you left out
in the house and there's a show business
yeah the health and days of Show
Business everything
no you can add that no I hit him on once
and and he was on with Eileen Heckard
with another guest and I got a lovely
note from the great Eileen hackard
saying how nice it was to be on the show
but next time perhaps without Mr Pig
[Laughter]
I heard that in the later years gessel
used to go over to Groucho's house not
so much as a friend but to to have him
give him money yes because he had
alimony with at least seven underage
girls and two over aged girls and uh
Benny on one of these things one night
said I've known George
you know for 50 60 years
and to this day he has earned well over
eleven hundred dollars
so we're sitting in a nightclub forgive
my attempt at a Jewish dialect with my
husband and Milton Baio was up on the
stage
and Milton is doing his jokes and at one
point my husband said enough and he
yells out
my husband without a second thought says
right back Milton boy oh [__] you
I'm real
gessel he was on a roast once my friend
Robert Vader did my DVD sets knows
everything in Show Business
and you rarely hear something new
Jessel was at the far end of the long
table at the Rose it's not a very good
status thing to be at the far end
but there he was and he got up and he
said it's obligatory to do a joke about
Milton Boyle's [__]
it's supposed to be very long
I don't know how long it is
but I'm standing on it
terrible image yeah it certainly is we
got to sell the book properly uh Mr
Cabot oh yeah what can you tell us about
the the book Brief Encounters
if I don't get sued for the Noel coward
estate for the movie Brief Encounter
um
is a collection of my New York Times
blogs and it's about everybody and
people in the show business in public I
don't I don't think they don't ask me
what I'm going to write about um
provocative the ones that have gotten
some of the most reaction were kind of
obituary for James Gandolfini
columns about Johnny Johnathan Winters
and one that people of a certain age
can't quite get over because the Youth
of today who know nothing ahead of their
birth
um don't even know who Laurel and Hardy
were it was a moving company or what
and I spent an afternoon with Stan
Laurel for about three hours in his
apartment little apartment overlooking
the ocean Santa Monica how old was he
then
do you know that's a good question I'm
not sure he was in his 70s he lived
quite a number of more years he wrote
letters every day to his fans I remember
the first one I got was thank you for
your nice letter so graciously expressed
her thoughts so good and he was really a
giant and when I opened the door to his
apartment not believing that I was going
to go to bed that night having met Stan
Laurel who helped the fat man push the
piano box up the 95 stairs and it kept
coming that short one and Oscar
um
but the door opened and there was a nice
looking man he'd filled out a bit in the
face but the ear was recognizable
another part of the face was instantly
recognizable and then in the voice the I
think it's called in speech people a
bilateral bilateral sibilance
well that certainly is nice to meet you
it's sort of sound like this
and he told one thing I remember he said
people would come visit him and he said
I had some guy here and he did my voice
the whole time the dumb son of a [__]
did my voice
I said I was so embarrassed I didn't
know where to look
[Laughter]
so the Oscar on the TV no Showbiz
pictures
none
a picture about four by six of him with
Ollie wow with Ali with the Ali wow that
was not Muhammad yes
I'm sorry Oliver I thought you said I'll
leave okay yeah yeah you were right yeah
we all thought that wow what's weird
someone brought up to me and I and it's
it I find it weird too that I've never
heard Stan Laurel and Charlie Chaplin
ever referred to each other and they
came up together thank you for setting
me up with this I told him that see
no you you told me that Charlie Chaplin
was blowing his hands
they're under Walter windshield stash
there's a theme running through your
work yes
I I asked him um oh my God what did you
say just before that it reminded me of
anyway I asked there are always rumors
that you know they never spoke off
camera and everything
that wasn't true
but Hardy had no interest in the films
he couldn't wait to get out of the thing
and get on the golf course and Stan said
to me
you know I always saved babe it was
called babe babes Burns
till the last because it was so goddamn
mad that he couldn't get to the golf
course and so those great
burns on his face were saved but he
didn't have any interest in the movie he
didn't do anything to help him and Stan
worked until midnight editing and
changing and so forth and I said so you
two were friendly and he said yeah
I wish I could have gotten this untaped
um
he said I went over I'll stop doing the
voice I went over at Christmas once and
uh
I brought babe a present of some sort
and it was obvious that he hadn't gotten
anything for me
but that was all right he said
but he was babe was obviously
embarrassed and so he looked down under
the Christmas tree and he picked up a
very very expensive bottle of bourbon
and said you know this this is a great
bourbon
um
there's only one place you can get this
in Los Angeles
and he put it back down under the tree
how come Stan Laurel and Charlie Chaplin
oh that's the thing right yes
um you cue me better than anybody yes
now you were stuck in an elevator and a
girl
did you ever blow Wally Cox not in the
daytime
what does that mean it means
okay I was sort of annoyed but the great
great publishing event one year was that
finally
Charles Chaplin let out his
autobiography and it sold like crazy and
it was bore your ass off and over
melodramatic
description of his mother's insanity and
thus the fates dealt with Mother anybody
who could write the line thus the fates
dealt with mother has something wrong
with him yeah I'm not saying chaplain
wasn't talented
but I asked Stan about him and I said
you know what aside from the boredom of
his book
um there's a picture of you with him in
it
and the Carno Troop that they belong to
in England Coming to America for the
first time on the ship
and yet your name doesn't come up
anywhere in the book two having two
great comedians arrive at the same time
was too much for the little fellow
and he said
he didn't criticize my comment he just
said
it's a crime to mention me in the same
breath with Charlie
wow meaning he thought Charlie was that
much better yeah damn
fascinating wow he had a letter he gave
he said you might want to read this and
it was this beautifully handwritten
letter a couple Pages nice stationary
beautiful handwriting and in it first
paragraph I saw
glancing at it was I have always tried
to emulate you in so much of my work
Alec Guinness
he was flattered he he wrote that to me
it was one hour
it was duplicated
well again it's genuine class will I be
remembered for that anagram
we've already forgotten you today
no one has ever punched you
well uh you and I did one of the best uh
podcast ever yes yeah yeah you showed up
on L Gilbert Godfrey's amazing colossal
podcast on Gilbert gottfried.com that's
a mouthful that that was yeah you were
you were one of those guests that I love
when you just click on the mic and then
you could pretty much go out and see a
movie and come back
I loved your apartment with the Groucho
pictures somebody gave me a gigantic
Groucho painting yes yeah right next to
the Otto of Eichmann yeah
you all know the late Larry Gilbert of
my oh yeah king of comedy writers
do you remember the older ones
the head of the U.N for a while was
Court valdheim
of ostia osterich yeah
and then he wrote a biography
and right after his biography
autobiography came out it was discovered
that he had been in the SS
he didn't mention that
Larry Gilbert said there's a new disease
we have to worry about now
waldheimer as you forget you were a Nazi
I hope it came to his attention
yeah we gotta pay Mr Kevin this is
always a pleasure unbelievable well
promoting uh Brief Encounters new book
available now I think I'm going to
download this thing in my audible yeah
did you read it yeah and you know you'll
never believe this my wife woke me up
recently saying I'm married to a Grammy
Award nominee the a lot of the voice
book what do you call it the audio
audiobook was up for a Grammy nice
people love the audiobook right and they
say I say why it kills you to read your
own stuff from nine to five two days in
a row as you may know
um they said we do all the voices of the
people you talk about I I so do that
unconsciously but it's a very good
audiobook right yeah and it was in
spoken Arts a category that isn't quite
seen on the air
so you read uh you recorded yeah yeah
you read your own book because I I
recorded my audiobook I hated every
second doing it is murder because they
tell you how to talk it's they're like
okay slow down you have to enunciate
it's like I don't have to talk it's
annoying you want to take that line
again and I almost I got saying no if
that one's bad use it yeah why not yeah
see here's your voice yeah we gotta get
we got oh we have Jerry Cooney coming in
so I'm gonna pee yeah we're gonna take a
break I mean if you want to you're
welcome
we're not telling the Cabot to leave
that's yeah you want to stay through the
night no I'd like you to leave
yeah uh dickhavishow.com for all the old
shows we're meeting Wally Cox later
I bet he'd be named that
right you said a mouthful oh no blackout
all right let's take a quick break we'll
be back right back okay Opie and Jimmy
continue on with the show